i think there's a huge vacuum i think
there's a there's a distinct lack of
leadership
good leadership in the world today in
politics and in corporate
um uh and it's not it's not a sudden
thing
it's been a steady drumbeat uh it's been
a we've been moving in this direction
for quite so many years um
amazingly you can actually you can trace
it back to the sort of
mid to late 1970s where it's where it
first started
the seed was planted um there was a an
economist by the name of milton friedman
who theorized he proposed a theory of
the responsibility of business
that the responsibility of business was
to maximize profit
that was it that the the the business
only existed to make money
uh that was a new idea and a new theory
and that a business had a responsibility
primarily to its owners i.e the
shareholders
um and so uh we started to see
the rise of this new concept of
shareholder supremacy which means we
prioritize the wants needs and desires
of an external constituency
over a customer and employee which is
the exact same idea
as a coach trying to build a good team
by trying to appease the fans while
ignoring the players
that is the exact thing but for whatever
reason whatever you know we can we can
it's a com
it's a deeper discussion to go into
whatever the cultural things that were
going on at the time
that made this theory very appealing and
uh leaders started to experiment with
these ideas
so for example we saw the rise of
shareholders supremacy it did
not exist prior to the 80s and 90s it
was popularized in the 80s and 90s
by leaders like jack welch from general
electric and those like him
the use of mass layoffs to balance the
books did not exist prior to the 1980s
and you had these boom years of the 80s
and 90s where it was kind of
let's be honest much easier to make
money and so
we became a very selfish society where
money became the thing greed is good
gordon gecko all of these things
and we saw this steady drum beat of the
rise of selfishness
well as you see a rise of selfishness
over the course of time
those same people are going to make
their way into leadership positions as
they get older and get promoted
and before you know it we have our
governments our politics
our corporations uh all of these things
is now filled
with uh people who were raised on this
very finite selfish minded kind of
leadership
and that's where we find ourselves today
um uh you know it's embarrassing that i
have a career
i talk about trust and cooperation there
should be no demand for my work
but the fact that there is demand for my
work means that people recognize that
the environments in which they are
working
are uncomfortable and we want change we
want something different
um and and we are starting to speak out
and there is a sea change
um and i think i think it took it took
us 30 years to get to where we are now
it's going to take us 20 or 30 years to
unwind it so
i still think we have some some time to
go but the good news is we're marching
in the right direction
we're talking about good leadership
we're starting to reject
leadership of the past we no longer
uh admire jack welch you know he's
fallen off his pedestal
these are all good steps in the right
direction
you